زينينسكي اوقع جيشه في الفخ
الروسي. هكذا اعلنها الامريكان.
والرئيس الاوكراني يؤكد ليس
لدينا القدرة على شن هجوم على
الروس. فهل انتهت اسلحة الغرب?
ام انتهى الجيش الاوكراني? موسكو
تحضر اربعمائة الف جندي للانقضاض
على اوكرانيا. وكييف تعلن مقتل
الف جندي روسي خلال اربع وعشرين
ساعة. وبوتين يرسل لدون صديقة
اسلحة نووية. فما الذي يجري?
اوروبا تضع ثقلها على التنين
الصيني لايجاد حل للازمة
الاوكرانية. وللمرة الثانية بكين
تهاجم مدمرة امريكية قائلة عليكم
تحمل نتائج افعالكم. وزعيم كوريا
الشمالية يبدأ رده الحاسم بغواصة
نووية مرعبة. اثيوبيا تعلن تحدي
مصر والسودان رسميا وماكرون يعود
للجزائر. والحرب بين امريكا
وايران تشتعل في سوريا. وهجوم
جوي يستهدف موكب وزير الدفاع
اليمني ورئيس الاركان. فهل تلفظ
الهدنة اليمنية انفاسها الاخيرة
هنا? بوتين يحضر اسلحته المدمرة.
حرب اوكرانيا تواصل حصد الارواح.
وعداد القتلى لا يتوقف وانهار
الدماء تسيل في الارجاء. نعم. هي
هيئة الاركان العامة للقوات
الاوكرانية تعلن انها قتلت اكثر
من الف عسكري روسي في اربع
وعشرين ساعة خلال معاركها مع
القوات الروسية التي شنت نحو
اربعين غارة خلال الفترة ذاتها.
وقدرت الهيئة الخسائر الروسية
منذ بدء الحرب بنحو مائة وسبعين
الف قتيل. وفق قول الهيئة
الاوكرانية. فهل هذه الارقام
حقيقية برأيكم? لترد الدفاع
الروسية ان قواتها تمكنت من
القضاء على نحو اربعمائة جندي
اوكراني على خمسة محاور قتال
اساسية خلال يومه ليسخن الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين الاجواء
قليلا. باعلانه ان بلاده نشرت في
بلاروسيا عشر طائرات قادرة على
حمل اسلحة نووية تكتيكية. فما
الذي يحضر له بوتين بالقرب من
اوكرانيا وعلى حدود اليكم
المصدر. اعلن الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين نشر اسلحة نووية
تكتيكية الى روسيا عبر عشر
طائرات مخصصة لهذا الغرض. بوتين
اضاف ان عملية النشر عبارة عن
اعادة تموضع في الحقيقة فالدب
الروسي يستعد لمعركة طويلة
الامد. بوتين يدرك ان روسيا امام
مصير حاسم ليصدر توجيهات غير
رسمية بتوسيع نطاق القوات ورفع
عدد العاملين في الجيش لتكشف
واشنطن عن حملة عسكرية روسية
لتجنيد اربعمائة الف متعاقد عوضا
عن تعبئة جديدة ومعظم المتعاقدين
من العسكريين القدماء والريفيين
بحسب بلومبرج. حتى ان نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن الروسي دميتري
ميدفيديف اعلن تحضر موسكو لرفع
عدد الجيش الى مليون ونصف
المليون جندي. فعن اي استعداد
نتحدث? من الاستعداد للحرب الى
الحرب ذاتها في اوكرانيا. ومع
تحول القتال في باخموت الى حرب
استنزاف للطرفين الروسي
والاوكراني. هذه الحرب تستهلك
الجنود والذخائر هنا يجمع قادة
الغرب اعدادا ضخمة من القذائف
والذخائر لايصالها لاوكرانيا حيث
صادق قادة الاتحاد الاوروبي في
بروكسل على خطة تهدف لتزويد
اوكرانيا بمليون قذيفة خلال عشر
شهرا بقيمة تعادل ملياري يورو.
فيالى سخاءكم الحاتمي يا هؤلاء.
ليعود بوتين مشيرا الى ان روسيا
تمتلك الكثير من الاسلحة التي لم
تستخدمها بعد. والحليب تكفيه
الاشارة ايها الغربيون. بينما
قال قائد القوات البرية
الاوكرانية ان قواته ستبدأ قريبا
هجوما مضادا في باخموت بعد صمدت
في وجه الحملة العسكرية التي
شنتها روسيا طوال الشتاء. فهل
لديك ما يكفي لذلك يا هذا؟
الاجابة جاءت باعتراف من الرئيس
زينونسكي بان قوات لا يمكنها في
الوقت الراهن شن هجوم مضاد على
المحور الشرقي في باخموت ؟ مبررا
ذلك بنقص الاسلحة مخازن الغرب
تنضب يا زلنسكي. فمن اين سيمدونك
بما تريد ليخرج المستشار السابق
للبنتاجون دوجلاس ماغويجر والذي
قال ان الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي
بارساله حشودا كبيرة من قواته
الى باخموت فقد اوقع جيشه في فخ
القوات الروسية هناك. ومن بين
ركام الاخبار جاء خبر انجليزي
عاجل. حيث صرحت الدفاع البريطاني
ان الهجوم الروسي العنيف على
باخموت الاوكراني توقف بشكل
كبير. فالقوات اصيبت بالارهاق
فهل هي كذلك حقا? ومن ضجيج اصوات
المدافع والقذائف الى هدوء
السلام. هنا زينسكي يعلن ان
بلاده لم تتلقى اي عرض صيني
للوساطة والحوار او للقاء الرئيس
الصيني مضيفا انه طلب من بكين
التعاون فيما يتعلق بخطة السلام
الاوكراني. اذا الرئيس الاوكراني
يلهث وراء محادثة جين بينغ فهل
خارت قواه وحان وقت الاستسلام
ولكن بوجه مشرف بينما اشارت
صحيفة فاينانشيال تايمز الى ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي يضغط على
الرئيس الصيني شي جين بينغ
باجراء محادثات مع نظيره
الاوكراني ويقول الاتحاد ان بكين
يجب ان تضغط وتسعى للحوار مع
كييف مثلما تفعل مع موسكو بل
اقتنع الاتحاد بان بكين فقط هي
من على فك عقدة الازمة
الاوكرانية. خلال ذلك قال الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن ان الصين لم
تزود روسيا باسلحة مهمة بعد،
مضيفا انا لا استخف بالصين انا
لا استخف بروسيا. معتبرا ان
التقارير عن التقارب بينهما ربما
كانت مبالغا بها. هجمة قوية للرد
على الامريكان. استفزاز من هذا
يقابله رد قوي من الطرف الاخر.
وبين اليوم والامس يبقى الرد
الصيني على واشنطن واحدا بعد ان
استسلمت الحكمة الصينية لتكون
القوة هي عنوان بكين امام
الامريكان. وهي الدفاع الصيني
تعلن انها اضطرت مجددا لابعاد
المدمرة الامريكية يو اس اس
ماليوس التي دخلت مياهها
الاقليمية في بحر جنوب الصين.
مطالبة امريكا حزم التوقف عن
الاعمال الاستفزازية والا فان
واشنطن عليها ان تتحمل التداعيات
الخطيرة لهذه الحوادث غير
المتوقعة وفق الوزارة الصينية.
بينما تصر واشنطن ان مدمرتها
تقوم بنشاطها وفقا لحقوقها
وحرياتها الملاحية فكيف ستنتهي
هذه الاستفزازات الامريكية. كيم
يخرج سلاحا مرعبا. يبدو ان
الصواريخ لم تكف لردعكم. حسنا
انتظروا ما هو اعظم. هكذا اعلنها
الزعيم الكوري الشمالي كيم جونج
اون. وذلك باعلان اختبار بلاده
غواصة جديدة قادرة على شن هجوم
نووي مهمتها التسبب في تسونامي
اشعاعي واسع للمنطقة. ردا على
المناورة الامريكية مع جارتها
الجنوبية. الغواصة يمكن نشرها
على اي ساحل او ميناء سحبها
بسفينة سطحية جاء ذلك بعد تجربة
اطلاق اربعة صواريخ كروز وكذلك
قبل اطلاق صاروخ سبعة عشر العابر
للقارات احد اكبر الصواريخ في
العالم. كم بدأ بهذه الغواصة
اجراءات الساحقة التي توعد بها.
فكيف سترد واشنطن وسيول الاحداث
والتطورات؟ اعلنت السلطات
الاثيوبية اكتمال تسعين بالمئة
من بناء سد النهضة رغم ما وصفته
بالتحديات والضغوط الدبلوماسية
والحرب الداخلية. فرنسا
والجزائر. تطويان صفحة الخلافات
بين البلدين بعد اتصال هاتفي
اجراه الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل
ماكرون بنظيره الجزائري
عبدالمجيد تبون عقب التوتر بخصوص
الناشطة الجزائرية اميرة بوراوي.
فهل عاد ماكرون معتذرا اعلام
يمنية تعلن ان طائرات مسيرة
استهدفت موكب وزير الدفاع ورئيس
هيئة الاركان ومحافظ تعز
والحوثيون ينفون اي صلة لهم
بالحادث. منسوب التوتر الامريكي
الايراني يبلغ حدا خطيرا في
سوريا. وبعد هجوم بطائرة مسيرة
ايرانية الصنع على قاعدة امريكية
قتل متعاقد امريكي واصيب ستة
اخرون. ليأمر الرئيس الامريكي
برد سريع. فقتلت الغارات
الامريكية اربعة عشر مقاتلا
مواليا لايران. حبس العالم
انفاسه وهو يترقب الخطوة
الامريكية اللاحقة ضد الموالين
لايران في سوريا. لكن بايدن هدأ
من روعه قليلا واعلن ان الولايات
المتحدة لا تسعى الى صراع مع
ايران. لتتواصل الغارات
الامريكية مرة اخرى ويرتفع عدد
القتلى الموال لايران الى تسعة
عشر. فهل تشتعل المواجهة بين
طهران وواشنطن? بوتين يحضر
اسلحته المرعبة على اطراف
اوكران. واوروبا تستنجد بالتنين
الصيني لايقاف حرب الدب الروسي
على الاوكران. فالى اين ستؤول
الاحداث بعد هذه التطورات?